hello reject nation it is like almost
100 degrees outside and this is the room
with the least amount of ac airflow but
because it's this movie i'm gonna wear this
beanie it's for the video for you guys
this is daredevil director's cut gonna
do a movie reaction to the ben affleck
led film john has never seen this film
i saw the theatrical version 19 years ago
needless to say i think i only really remember
a moment one or two months like yeah i kind of
remember that it's gonna be pretty much a brand
new movie for me and it's also a half hour longer
than the theatrical cut and i've heard it's so
much better guys so full-length watch long recycle
with the time code for daredevil we'll be over
at our patreon page cover a whole bunch of
stuff over there as well your support means
a lot thank you super rejects leave a like if you
enjoy this one and uh thanks the boys at prepper
help us edit this down gonna be doing more
movie reactions so keep a lookout let's do this
they say your whole life flashes before your eyes
when you die and it's true even for a blind man
come on trip hit me i'll give you a free shot
is that anthony soprano i told you i didn't
want you fighting i tried to walk away like you
said but they kept giving me [ __ ] don't turn
you think i'd be pulling double overtime down
at the docks i was working for fallon what
are you nuts you don't hit nothing with
books get me you'll be a doctor a lawyer
not like me foreshadowing you can do anything
if you're not afraid now you promised me
that's gotta be the theme
of this movie i promise dad
why would it tie out rope around the moon
matt lasso's the moon looking from
my dad jack murdock seen him around
murdock he worked here in months i'll beat it huh
i love that his hair's a little red i know
oh he got good grades you're
gonna need that report card though
we're close to the docks matt
wow
wow so his senses were like instantaneously
enhanced that's what happens when you go blind
whoa
jesus will save you young matu
talked to the doctor i'm blind i know i heard
you talking in his office i hear everything
i'm an adult now dad
i mean doesn't make you automatically good
at that you know no in this case it does
and acute sense of touch nice hot head shot
hey
grunkle stan what's up freak show up in the exact
same way same out go ahead fight me
i dare you yeah murdock i dare ya
fight
i don't work for you no more fallon jack
you never stopped better call saul brigade
something that feels borderline dick tracy-ish
about this uh what's it gonna call it's flashbacks
it's a cane hotter all right bernard
you all right okay let's fight
oh no oh boy
this is currently feeling like a
well-made crowd-funded daredevil
absolutely that's a good call
and
parents died in alleyway
ouch i would seek justice one way or another
i have enjoyed the symmetry of a lot of
the shots the production design does feel
very much like a graphic novel oh yeah
those sexy ass knees
pop yourself up drown the world out in rock
anything that happened after
that was entirely consensual
okay are you aware that perjury is a crime mr
casanova my client is a respectable member of
the community that only makes her testimonials
her testimony gentlemen that's enough there's
something i just haven't enjoyed every
minute of it oh god that's disturbing
this this scene is aged into greater
relevance not tonight you got work to do
get to work boy yes
oh yeah post schumacher world
yes i love it
yes
ah we're both horny yeah it's
for real what do you want justice
nice
oh that was great uh-huh that
was really cool solid action dude
skateboard never lose those skills
i do like the gothic flare man
trains are his weakness
you're dead
oh no
go to hell diablo okay you'll beat me there
wow
that light the end of the tunnel
guess what that's not heaven
this is something a little more badass
you know no i'm going to use that now jose
oh my god oh nice he's straight up killed
him yeah dude got a train right over the
nuts there is no proof that your so-called
daredevil was involved nor that he even exists
too cause it's wet all over here
there's no comic book movie like this to deck look
at that oh yeah brooding shower shot you know we
need some better clients i'm tired of these pro
bono cases what's your problem with our clients
we have we have good honorable clients decent
people what's your idea of better to define better
huh what would be a better client
it's in law school how to create a moral vacuum
yeah you can represent people who aren't all
necessarily innocent it's your best course
as i recall yeah well you don't have them all
i mean i hate to bring it up again
but i spent three thousand dollars
on seeing eye dog i didn't ask you
for the dog i didn't want a dog
ex-wife oh she the other jennifer she's
hideous i don't know if it's a fungus or
some sort of congenital birth defect but as
you're returning in this matter i advise you
i was just looking for some honey could
you help me out right in front of you
could you be a little bit more specific what
are you blind yeah i am so sorry that's okay
i tell you some people have no compassion
for the handicap apparently not
where you going get that [ __ ] compassion
you can start acting pitiful right now
i don't like being followed so don't wait a
second take it easy i don't like being touched
yeah why don't you tell me what
you do like we'll start there
is not the time place it's a fight date
usually a question is blind ability now
sure you're blind okay i'm sure
you don't wanna tell me your name
this is the best movie
oh yes you're holding back yes
my name's electro nachos we call him
the master that's all i wanted to know
terrible terrible way to cover up your abilities
how am i gonna find you you
won't i'll find you oh yeah
dad i'm looking for an insanely talented
blind man living in hell's kitchen
i think i can narrow that down out of
their bodyguards their first day on the job
you think that's horrible don't you because
you don't like the physical stuff i do
good eye acting on that guy i want you to buy me
out i think you'll find it's a very generous offer
how's your daughter great
cigar acting in that scene
dante jackson next con from queens charged
with the august 9th murder of lisa tazio
your friendly neighborhood
prostitute spider-man reference
jackson cooley holy [ __ ] we're your
attorneys oh here it goes so are you edison
hell yeah i believe you you do you do you
got yourself a defense no foggy's racist
that seems who she is press want a kingpin
so i'll give him a kingpin give me bullseye
bullseye eye
oh my god how many paper clips did he have how
deep did they all go why does he have a paper clip
the [ __ ] the matrix is a system neo
and it was never a bad time to be cool
huh gross
how badass he is even dogs know
ah i see come on matt there's nothing over
there let's go it's a mac m-m-o-o-m-m-6
six eight eight there i knew it
her mother did it nikoi please go
get me a computer for christmas last
you can still hear her over
those headphones i said
what just straight up murdering he's just
dead now can i get you anything before we land
more peanuts ladies i got a whole other
movie look at this it's so beautiful i know
this is my favorite view of the city when
i was a kid i really wanted you to see this
describe it to me
when we were kicking each other's ass in the park
i knew you were the one first time it falls on a
surface just then it's like it's like i can see
again and i i just want to i just want to see you
damn i totally banged this guy
charming jeez jesus dude oh wow
it's pretty accurate
they're instantly soaked
i have to go matt
damn he hasn't been daredevil for like 30 minutes
please don't hurt me i'm not the bad guy kid
i'm not the bad guy conflict how would you
even consider that you're beating up obviously
very horrible people that's your whole thing
cool color i wouldn't know we can't represent you
why is that yes why is that mr murdock because
we only handle clients who are innocent
ouch you know i've learned one thing
in all my years in this business
what's that nobody's innocent especially the blind
it's like that
you want me to take you up there matt
matt matt hitting people out of the way
everyone i could sense how hot she is tonight
but the only reason i got dressed up for this
thing was that i wanted to look beautiful for you
i banged her too i bet both same time let's
do this eiffel tower go back to the party day
what's wrong your name is too stop
russ will take you home saint paul
oh yeah
i'm sorry
how could you just leave yeah how [ __ ] rude
i have never i wouldn't know i'm the blind one
uh here we go
oh there you go this part of
new york looks like downtown l.a
drop something
no way come on man
with his own weapon no
damn
well if i had to point out bullseye i know
how did you get past my security [ __ ] you made
that good yeah oh god you know you've exceeded
all my expectations you're hired have you ever
owned a handgun mr jackson no sir do you have
any intention of owning a handgun mr jackson no
sir thank you can't hit nothing with a handgun
but a shotgun now that's a whole different
story shotgun's got bug shot it's like
little thank you that's all and when you
shoot it they kind of spray out like that
so it could just hit everything in front
of it thank you mr jackson for your sake
i hope your partner comes back soon you
are a terrible lawyer son suppressed
we killed her daddy watch you
upset that's just how things go
who left the red rose there who
killed lisa tazio aren't they jacks
i want to know what your copy of everything
it's the key to beating daredevil
just get a pacemaker oh that
that's matt's big contribution to the tazio
case which has uh surprisingly turned out to
be completely useless flip it upside down
what's the date of the murder august 9th
why maybe you're looking at it flip
it upside down oh what brilliant
did say matt murdock had a martial arts battle
in the park yeah several children spotted him
this is not a good time it's about lisa tazio
i remember this the song on the trailers
the director of this movie do music videos
there's so many needle drops in this movie
she's really good at that [ __ ] holy crap yeah
it's convincing well in size no easy business
i still look hot wait until matt sees
me next it was a hitman named bullseye
i didn't kill your father
liar gotta have your cool action boys
the flight ability on these people is
insane yeah their legs must be jacked
oh you could have at least dodged that
listen to me you have to
take a drink every time he
spreads his arms out that way
oh [ __ ] it went through her hand huh yeah nice
why'd you try to catch it cause i'm bullseye
why'd she try to catch it yeah that's
a great question because dodged it
oh my god goodness that is probably super
painful good jesus christ high velocity papercut
that is brutal something more brutal
about it did not piercing the shirt yeah
i don't remember eddie i was literally
like nope no recollection of this
oh she was only a lecturer for like five minutes
don't worry there will be a
whole movie oh yeah oh yeah
how the what how do you get there
movie magic
i don't ask for mercy people ask me
don't you dare touch the priest
how did you not catch that
venom i was just gonna say that
goofy physics there what does it call it for
i don't know what color pearl's doing
but i'm weirdly enjoying what the hell
that's awesome biscuits the kingpin
yeah the whole red rose thing he
loves that [ __ ] it's not my style
my gosh during the red rose thing
for decades no it all makes sense
the way they did that was awesome yeah
jesus
so both his daredevil and batman just
straight up murder yeah it's in his contract
touch your forehead one last one
i would say this is a better schumacher movie
like a reverse bane
good stunt performers in this one
holy crap that is so painful
hmm
why not kill him i'm not the bad guy
he just threw bull's eye out the window
strapping that one guy to the train tracks and
throwing bullseye to his death
really taught me something
all right all right this scene was added back in
you're not [ __ ] jennifer garner you're just a
stand-in for jennifer garner i
know the truth about daredevil
justice is blind huh if you run that story i'm
finished but i'm a reporter kid it's what i do
throw your stick at him kill him
because evil always survives
with the help
like a weird bulldog or something
that plays that character
yes
in case he had to remind himself
soon the world will know the truth
that this is a city born of heroes control z
chose a princess yeah
good thing there doesn't dare to vote
and take on litterers a guardian devil
a dark knight
killing it
wow
can't wait for the sequel
it's gonna be so good i can't wait to get
everyone back dude ellen pompeo was in this dang
dude david keith and keith david
should be in a movie together
david david keith the actor who
played matt murdock's father
yes yes and keith david veteran actor
and great voice yeah they could play
brothers they could biological brothers in
a new remake of twins well john while we
i don't know if there's a post-credits season
while we wait for the new post-credit scenes then
um somebody had to i believe iron man
was the one that really kicked it off
that iron man is definitely the one that made it
like you expected it and if you don't get one it's
weird i don't remember if they were already
doing it back then maybe it looks like it
no black it was a lot of black for no
reason what the hell was that about
it i don't know such a big gap in the
credits there the article exposing matt
murdock was supposed to go there but then
they deleted it what did you think about
daredevil oh boy it was a special experience
you know this is a fascinating movie experience
because it's intermittently you know way better
than i've heard the theatrical cut of daredevil is
i can also kind of imagine what might have gotten
cut out and what the theatrical experience might
have looked and been like because of some of
the it felt like it was sort of like dipping
in and out of something that was pleasurably
cheesy in a way and you know it had that sort of
early 2000s comic book attitude where it's
like we gotta make cool and punchy all the time
uh so yeah i mean it's definitely of its time
but i had a good time and and and what leaves
the impression on me right at this moment is
that you know for an almost 20 year old movie
at the time of recording this you know there's
a fair amount more that holds up than i expected
true especially in the construction of the effects
and some of the fights um there's definitely some
really silly stuff but uh but not bad not bad
i think from what i've heard over the years
is what got cut out of the movie was a lot of
lawyer stuff okay a lot of actual lawyering so
and and i don't i on i mean i don't
remember like 99 of this movie um
the only thing i kind of remembered was uh when
electro was training okay besides but i don't
remember thinking like oh she's actually really
good with that stuff that was a that was a cool
scene yeah yeah and she really it's weird out of
everything sandbags dropping from i have no idea
she must they're stupid rich so she must have a
system of police stop watches and who knows what
else or maybe there's an alfred style butler are
they specifically designed to stab and break are
they designed to kick and punch because i'm
like how many sandbags are you going through
yeah practicing with these sides you gotta get
a whole new set every single time this cannot be
the most practical way to slicing them open like
but they're just still you know get something else
that doesn't just break open um yeah i think
so i think it might have been all the coolio
stuff that was cut i can't imagine i mean i i
enjoyed his his presence here and and weirdly
but i feel like it's not needed i'm like wait how
exactly does this even play into the main plot
yeah i mean like it's tangential because of
the way that yeah like the the girl who was
murdered the prostitute who he's being framed
for the murder of is actually the guy who uh
wow killed or there's actually the woman wow
killed but at the same time i'm like i feel
like there are other parts of the plot that
would have gotten us there eventually or at
least he interrogates the cop in the car
we'd at least have gotten to wilson fisk
so yeah i wonder if maybe the some of the figuring
out of you know who's to blame on matt murdock's
side you know maybe that played differently in
the theatrical cut or or was plotted slightly
differently because yeah i feel like aside
from that one bit of connective tissue you
can just remove that and nothing really happens
although i did appreciate that this had kind of a
for the time it was made the portrayal of like
crime and and how it affects like people who
are down on their luck and how those people get
exploited at the whims of you know the people
who run thing like that stuff actually checked
better than i expected uh for a movie like this
so no sounds like you really liked it a lot
i loved this movie they even laid down one
criticism so far oh there's i mean there's tons
of cheese and i mean i would say that the first
maybe half hour 40 minutes or so uh it was like
this is really cool and fun and like you know
the the the combination of the effects with like
the film stock because it's still shot on film
and everything i i believe uh you know like
it's definitely shot on film yeah and so like
she brings that nostalgic effect everything's so
digital now yeah and then there's something about
that that makes it feel a bit more tangible
anyway so for the first hour i was like i can
see what people mean that this is like
significantly like nothing feels that silly
for the most part and then you know it started
to it's weird it's like i appreciate what they
included and that they have all the lawyering
and all that stuff nobody's credit scene ah
continued but as i was saying you know
sort of towards the middle of the movie
it does start to sort of sag under the weight
of all the stuff that it's doing and i feel like
the kingpin and bullseye are in a slightly
different movie from everybody else which i have
a sneaking suspicion probably would have played
better in the theatrical cut but at the expense
of everything else playing worse in the theatrical
cut so like this is a it's probably true that's a
good way to think about it yeah and so i know what
you're saying yeah because like they get more real
with the crime investigation and uh yeah like oh
he's going into the the victim's house and they're
doing actual trials and this is all surprisingly
grounded [ __ ] yeah and then you got like
not quite but almost shoe mockery villains there
like there's like some parts that were like i'm
getting some two-faced riddler flashbacks
here it's not that qui it's not that quite
as big but it feels like it would fit more in that
universe for the kind of extended version this is
i think you're you're both your name checks all
right i feel like this is a what would happen if
you spliced the tim burton batman aesthetic with
the schumacher batman aesthetic because like there
is that sort of even though new york isn't quite
something there's got a lot of crow in there too
yeah yeah it's got that gothic sort of thing going
on and it's got a certain height about it which
sometimes helps the cheese and sometimes really
doesn't help the cheese i mean there's so much
stuff in this movie that feels like a teenager
going look how cool this is it feels like a
crowd made daredevil yeah like this is really
well made these guys could be great filmmakers
yeah give them a real budget and some real
resources see what they can do yeah absolutely
because yeah there's a lot of shots that feel very
much like we're looking at a comic book panel i
actually really thought a lot of
the cinematography other than the
wildly apparent we gotta really shadow
this up because we're using a lot of cgi
yeah other than the very apparent moments were
there and you know to be fair this is 2 000 they
must have made this in 2002 this got released
in 2003. so there's there's been a much bigger
evolution and visual effects since then not to
say that's always great but i think that with
what they're doing here with the amount of zipping
around is the super heroism that sometimes the the
rules of the anatomy i was like i love move
faster i'm still questioning it though like
do you guys get hurt like regular humans
but you know yes like superheroes that's
like one of the craziest so you can leap
literally tall buildings in a single valley
so how heightened are we going right now why is it
only that your leaps are that jacked whereas like
you know that if your muscles are that way under
this reality would stand to reason that like any
punch would just knock someone's head off you know
for some reason the because the style of it read
as cheesy versus when you're watching like a hong
kong film like a crouching tiger for example where
you're like no that's the fighting style but they
can still get hurt like humans for some reason it
doesn't this register is like goofy or versa
i don't know why um i think it's too it's just
the combination of all that stuff with then the
leather and the rock music and it's just so much
piled on yeah and you do have this well i think
those hong kong movies strike a more fantastical
tone and where this strikes like we're a dark
gritty like [ __ ] punk and yeah yeah but we do
leaps and bounds we get hurt like regular humans
and we do a lot of like it's it's not quite as
as expressionist and stylized as like a a chinese
opera like a wusha kind of movie but they do a lot
of still those wire effects that are a little more
heightened of like when people are it makes the
most sense when wilson fisk is throwing people
around because it's supposed to be like oh wow
he's just got so much brute strength yeah he can
toss a guy you know further across the room than
you would ever imagine and and those moments the
physics play a little better but there is kind
of an a certain element of that wire work that
adds a certain fantastical like the physics of
this movie are a little all over the place i would
argue what's funny to me is that in a lot of ways
was weird watching in the context of like
watching ben affleck do this role that made me go
it's like what he did with like when he did
batman it was a redo of how he could have done
daredevil better you know because there's so he
the way he plays matt burdock is a bad boy he
plays him like a bad boy you know as i i wasn't
even really comparing him to charlie cox i wasn't
even like thinking about that if anything just
found myself thinking of like ben affleck's batman
yeah because actually if i did compare charlie cox
charlie cox brings more of a boyish sweetness to
the role whereas matt murdock in ben affleck's
is very short fused and aggressive and then like
oh i'm into this chick yeah let's play a rough and
dirty you know chase after her despite her protest
oh my god this cops pissing me off i'm gonna
jack his car i'm gonna like crash it yeah yeah
you know like as opposed to like charlie cox which
plays the duality of who he is as like that torn
tortured the way how he has that line in here like
i'm not the bad guy like i feel like with charlie
cox you really get that sense of struggle or when
that came in here i'm like i didn't really get the
sense of struggling no it's just the switch flips
of i'm not gonna let a train cut a guy in half
you killed that guy you broke his um uh
what did he break and there was his rib
cage or something i forgot he broke there
in that moment oh oh yeah that's who uh
i totally forgot he broke right through his
sternum yeah and then and then he fell in the
train tracks yeah yeah murdered the guy
that bears up oh boy and uh bullseye if
i find myself occasionally questioning the
rules which is strange for me to do in a
comic book movie because i i normally don't when
it comes to anything but the physics i really i
don't ever really like go wait a minute what but
this movie had me doing that from time to time
yeah um but i i did i did uh i didn't dislike it
i actually thought it was totally it's above more
views for me that's the new scale i mean people
the way people hype the director's cut i imagine
it must be the feeling that people who are not
into snyder's vision of justice league must feel
like for me i'm like i really think that zack
snyder's justice league movie is a fantastic film
i really believe that but i know there's people
who just can't and don't don't enjoy it who watch
so they'll watch joss whedon's cut and go that's
terrible and then they watch zach snyder's cut
and they go i still don't like it but it's better
even though i don't remember the theatrical cut
i have a feeling that's more what my response to
this would be is yeah like uh it's fine and like
it's not i don't think it's a terrible film by
any means like there's some questionable stuff
and there's a kind of it's a kind of drag
and get a little bit dull yeah weirdly it's
with the bullseye part when he comes in where i
feel like that's when the movie should be the most
elevated and exciting for some reason it just
felt like we were now getting amazing spider-man 2
syndrome [ __ ] where you're just like you're over
introducing too much like the collector's dad then
die there's there's so many plots happening here
even in your director's club which is the extended
version even in the extended version which if
i'm not mistaken they did cut out a whole other
plot which was the coolio thing so they have you
know like when alexa when elektra's dad dies and
then it's oh it's a lecturer's revenge around it's
like 10 minutes of the movie you know yeah it's
too much there's not enough to breathe so i didn't
feel much when i was watching this like i felt
like kind of empty on my experience other than
being amused by certain elements here or there
or appreciating the i think the most consistent
thing i appreciated was the production design
and uh cinematography and a lot of that i i
like that like really grainy grimy ugly filming
things to that yeah from the 90s and [ __ ]
i really liked that um and i think some of
the fighting was cool and i think ben affleck
does a fine job here i i do find myself going
this it really did feel like his batman was a
was a better version of what he was doing as
daredevil for me absolutely partly my thing
i think the thing i i'm finally starting to
put my finger on is just i rarely don't see ben
affleck when he's in anything i'm usually like
ben affleck you know and here i was like it's
ben affleck i i like what he's doing i i think
he's charming and and you know his bad boy take
on the role i am enjoying but i don't really see
past the fact that it's you know one of
hollywood's biggest stars ben affleck
he doesn't do a bad job in it no not at all not
at all i think he does a pretty good job and i
mean he and jennifer garner have such chemistry
yes it's crazy like i i really was endeared and
i like the romance between them yeah and that
could have felt requisite or cheesy and it's
moments like that like things like that i wasn't
expecting like that moment on the rooftop where
we were at first laughing about it being kind of
cheesy like when it starts to rain and you see
the the vision he described like it's like i can
see you for the first time like that actually
touched me and i was like that's kind of beautiful
actually like that's a nuance i hadn't expected
from this movie and i feel like part of what
uh starts to drag and undercut characters like
funny enough i came in expecting everyone had
always told me that bullseye and kingpin are the
best parts and i watched this and the thing that
kind of hampers those two for me is that you know
you're so one note well yeah there's just nothing
to those characters except the immediate moment of
them being maniacal and so they give you stuff to
kind of latch onto or they characterize everybody
else and they don't characterize them beyond what
the actors are doing right now so especially when
uh when bullseye keeps showing up it's like
you're literally just cutting to a different
rock music video for a couple seconds while he
does some cool thing says a lot like a badass quip
and then touches his head and it's like you know
you're you're pumping in like a matrix music video
and then cutting back to a real movie yeah
periodically and so yeah there is like a weird
disjointed quality that they bring that if you're
not like 100 with it does kind of drag or or does
kind of leave you looking at the periphery and
thinking about the construction or things that
you shouldn't be thinking about when you should
be just pulled into you know what's going on
yeah it's a silly phone is it i i i don't know
i'm so conflicted about it because i think i
like the first 40 minutes more than anything else
absolutely i agree i think the first 40 minutes
are striking the right balance of you're taking
yourself really serious but then you're you're
you know like you're sometimes you're so fun
you're so cheesy that uh like i love it i just
love that some of the some of the dialogue is so
bad sometimes that just cracks me up and i'm like
i don't mind it it's funny and um but sometimes
the violence really does hit i'm like oh my god
that's violent yeah you know yeah in a way that's
not overly grotesque but it still hits yeah
yeah i think that's like pretty impressive
and how they did that i like the first fight
a lot with daredevil and the people in the bar
mm-hmm um i like him and john favreau together
yeah you know john favreau's fully john
forever that's doing the job fam birthday
i liked him like there's not much
difference between here and happy
he's just dropped fabric and the fur that's good
is good daredevil didn't get to that point because
he would just be he's happy with this franchise
after a while yeah like i like that and i do agree
on the the column feral parts were depending on
the scene at times very amusing what he was doing
but in an isolated sense i enjoyed him a lot and
uh in the church fight like just how because he
gets a few misses he just like panics he's like
freaks out like my world is shattering my whole
my whole identity is based off of never missing he
just like freaks out and he pants like a dog like
literally i i feel like if i watch an interview
with him he'd be like i based my performance off
a bulldog yeah i know i think that's a good call
like because he really does have that sort of
like one track mind this like weird spunky energy
like let me add him let me add them yeah yeah it
definitely feels like a cartoon dog yeah it's it's
uh it's it's it's fascinating and i do think the
yeah they had like more heart and a good a better
flow but i think the i feel like there are things
about the kingpin performance that i i don't know
no disrespect to michael clark duncan who i think
is a wonderful actor and i i feel like he did what
the script would want him to do i i just had a
hard time getting on board with it for some reason
like it never struck me as menacing just goofy i
was never afraid i feel like we really should have
had at least one moment to br he kind of reminded
me of a very subdued version of tommy lee jones's
two-face and i feel like if we have had a moment
to really see all of that garish personality fade
away because even when he's fighting daredevil at
the end like there's there's laughing and there's
sort of his energy carries through that and
if we could see one instance of not one of his
goons taking care of something but of him doing
something totally terrible and deplorable i feel
like that would have helped a lot taking something
intensely serious and being threatening as opposed
to just always it's like that annoying go-to bad
guy thing for me like let's just really he's just
loving the smile and laughs always loving this
yeah where i'm like i might have been more
interested if you were if you played it offended
by him wanting to back out mm-hmm you know as
opposed to how's your daughter yeah i was hoping
you'd say yeah oh my god someone's just all right
threat the threats are so over the top yeah i like
joe pantaliano a lot too yeah he's great he's
still alive i forgot dude he passed away i break
i don't forget i feel like i haven't seen him
forever i haven't seen him in a while but i think
he's i think he's still with us i hope so um but i
think he's great i think i mean he's great in like
literally anything he does he's he's always great
um two actors in the sopranos were here and yeah
he was he was great in here and i really liked
the presence that he brought for ben urich and
like he feels like a real i really believe that
he would go through publishing the article yeah
yeah i got that but i also believe that he would
delete the article exactly like that's a really
good character for trail i think that played
really nice and that's and that's well within the
the tone here it's it's funny it's like i feel
like this is probably a much more consistent movie
than the theatrical cut is i feel like it's still
at odds with yeah the more bouncy fun aspects and
the more you know dark gothic aspects and i feel
like most issues you could have with this movie
sort of boil down to if they just proportioned
those things a bit better together but he is
a character who has a through line fits very
naturally with everything and i think ben affleck
does a really good job in the more despairing
moments of his performance when he's feeling
really hollow i think that he does a really good
job in those those key sequences you know um
actually i think he's like really good he's never
had a moment where i was like that's about acting
you know i never i never had anything like that uh
i just yeah i i did have the i never i did i was
always aware it was ben affleck yeah i was always
like ben affleck's doing a good job yeah you know
he's watching ben affleck yeah absolutely and hey
he must have he must have been the guy who brought
kevin smith in true true yeah that's a fun cameo
yeah i'm a bad actor like kevin smith but overall
yeah it's the same morpheus because my my
reaction to when it's all said and done is
it was fine it does get a little boring in the
middle honestly because that you just i just don't
care about any of the actual drama like the yeah
the drama is not gripping and i i honestly while
i appreciate the execution of the lawyer stuff and
i think coolio brings a lot of fun to it uh i did
find it unnecessary like ultimately to the point
that if it is cut out like i like the concept of
you actually get to see matt murdock do lawyer
[ __ ] versus in the theatrical cut i imagine
you don't really see him gonna do any of that so
i do appreciate that you get to see that i just
i wasn't that interested in it and so the
with a movie that is not as consistent with
its tone it gets really bogged down in a
lot of drama that i don't really care about
so it was most entertaining to me when there was
you know actual [ __ ] happening here that was
like look at them fight yeah you know they're
running around i'm building tops yeah look at
them have an argument that's actually engaging
or something like that but i'm not rooting for
i'm not rooting for matt murdock in this firm i'm
not rooting for the firm of of of foggy and nelson
uh i'm not really rooting for
anything to be totally honest
i don't really want ben affleck i'm like oh yeah
that's right kingpin killed your dad like yeah
i'm not it's easy i'm not rooting for him to get
revenge and i'm not rooting for a lecture to get
revenge i'm not there's nothing that this movie
makes me look forward to or that i'm fascinated by
or that i'm rooting for i'm just sort of amused
through most of it yeah it was a fun pleasant
watch and i feel like the most impact i got was
out of more of the technical aspects of just
being like wow this this holds up surprisingly
yeah there's some cool technical production yeah
like i think that but that wears off like
you get used to it and where it it wears thin
after a while uh to to the point where what's
the word i often hear with like michael bay
movies when you get used to the explosions
and all that there's this this is sort of
toes or something there's an actual phrase that
i hear all the time with the michael bay film
that if they obey him and something no just
something about yeah that would be numbing the
point that it's communicating is that like after a
while you you are just completely unaffected by it
and it becomes boring like sensory overload
uh that's not quite it no not your overload
it's not overwhelming it's just that appreciation
that has that elicits an emotional response from
me starts to wear off yeah and i stopped being
like oh but that is so cool to look at and you
know it's actually pretty neat for me and
that it was really in the first half hour
when i would see certain shots i'm like that's
pretty you don't see that in comic book movies
and to be to this movie's credit you don't get
like this is more bold than [ __ ] anything
sony's been doing with their dark marvel sony
characters spider-man or whatever the hell it's
called like this is more bold than any of
that the way they went here i think is this
the next step for the sony spider-man universe of
its dark characters should aspire to be more like
the daredevil's director's got this this is more
of what they ought to be like and i don't think
this movie was then again i don't really i don't
remember the theatrical cut so but going off of
this i'm like this is not a terrible film and i
can see why people really like it but the people
i see that really love it i i rarely encounter the
individual who's like i've never seen a theatrical
one i'm only saying director's cut uh but i think
that if you watch it the actual and then this
one you're like this is so much better because
because you saw that one you know yeah you have
the point of comparison like for me yeah this
is my first experience be on the trailers
and that promo they always used to run to theaters
about the choreography of the fights of this movie
chong yen yoon we call him the master uh
but yeah like this isn't like a movie i love
based off of this i'm like i'm glad i saw it i
would watch it again sometime if someone really
wanted to but i do agree that this has that dark
unit that dark sony spider-verse quality that i
feel much better than them it is it is i would
break this book it's a real movie it's like yeah
it's more consistent and it's more thought out
it feels like and it feels like it though it
feels like visually striking a lot of the time
and it seems like purposeful and how they did it
yeah and and the camp and the pulp that arises
from that often feels like it still kind of fits
instead of enjoying it despite itself they had
a lot of like composition to the way they were
framing this movie like this movie didn't feel
like let's figure this out in editing like it
feels like they mapped it out in storyboarded
scenes and how they were gonna visually graph
this film together like it feels intentional and
purposeful whereas a lot of these other ones feel
like like nowadays they just feel like a mess
yeah you know and this doesn't this does not
feel like a mess to me it just falls a little flat
for me yeah it'll be more dynamic and it could be
better fleshed in certain aspects yeah yeah and
i'm like even in the theatrical like there's some
things you just have to cut it's like something
needed to be just written out before filming
is the thing it wouldn't be like you could
have fixed this and like there's not a
version where you can fix this final product
in editing and by trimming some other stuff
out i would be like no you would have to start
with the screenplay and change some of that up
before filming the damn thing because yeah there
are things that definitely did not wait uh hit
as strong as they could have like those
emotional beats are not hit that strong
but hey glad i watched it finally you've
been counted for years to watch this film
uh thanks for being here subscribe click
that bell and hey let's uh do a patreon
scooba steve the devil scuba diving devil of
hell's kitchen out there in switzer sweden tagging
all the swiss walls with your prime prime with
your painted scuba crab but what you're really
doing is covering wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait what are you talking about steve scuba
esteban i was thinking of the other guy michael
linden oh we could do michael we could switch
let me go with scuba scuba hey whether
it's switzerland freaking rhode island
or okay whether hey hell's kitchen switzerland
rhode island sweden wherever you happen to be
all right thug cooper you're the sprayer who's
spray paints yeah he's just every single movie
that's also the one obsessed with horror and
there's always amazing yeah i remember scuba
yeah he's always tagging stuff that looks
like a horror movie or something like that
i know now we can do the shadow true horror
is crying yeah scuba thanks man thanks dog
thanks for raiders love you
buddy hope you're doing well man
send us some more obscure horror recommendations
you're a fantastic individual terrible job
if he only stopped interrupting me you know i
would have been able to nail that take it away
you